that's how are you I rub you guys thank
you so much
would want to see me
mark Duplass debut chron we wrote
directed Cyrus yes that is correct
and over here in 2006 with our first
movie the puffy chair and then we came
back to back
hump day that I acted in and this movie
is like our first video
ok
Alexa line I want to be a PA on Black
Swan so i can watch Darren for a great
filmmaker at work we
Aronofsky is that okay to say that yeah
yeah okay yeah
I don't know man I mean we we like to
shoot close-ups you like to shoot people
were obsessed with strange odd funny
people I think it might have something
to do with that you know or just being
dumb enough to keep making movies when I
were so bad for so long and then one day
we got lucky and we made
think about it too much because then
I'll have to go out there
we used to work as editors a lot you
know we worked as editors at a church
television series for a while they said
we need big ditches in a plantation and
we've at one time manually with a high
editor at Texas high school cheerleading
video that was pretty good there weren't
pleased with my work
we're actually we are picture locking
our movie it's called Jeff Lewis at home
stars Jason Segel in ten-towns tune
Sarandon and Judy Greer so we're even
need deep birkin we're kind of
workaholic so we don't really take spot
is no rest for the desperate yes thank
you